building a business is all about
recognizing
patterns and knowing which
move to make at the right time as soon
as you blame
shame or justify you are disempowering
yourself
i think feeling and knowing that you've
used your life in a way that makes
yourself
proud that you're proud of you you felt
like
what a journey and i left it all out on
the field
and i just left it all in the field
that's my own greatness
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best john assaraf and my take on his top
10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one recognize the patterns
is a misconception that
business is easy and
i have a lot of clients of mine for
example that are there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals
that have an expertise in a certain area
but nobody's ever taught them about
finance
about legal if they're not a lawyer
about marketing about sales about
technology
about operations about management
and being an entrepreneur is like
solving a rubik's cube
yes i see that right so you can have the
two by two
with two colors you know it's easy if
you want a little bit bigger business
that's three by three there's more
combinations and more things that need
to be considered
four by four now has billions of
different
moves just four by fours billions of
different possibilities
wow when you get to the 8 by 8 or 16 by
16 rubik's cube
there's quintillions of possible moves
that you can make
so building a business is all about
recognizing patterns and knowing
which move to make at the right time
and there's four options that you have
one is
do it yourself and try and figure it out
two is get help
three get it done for you or four don't
do it
rule number two write down your goals
did you
know that some of the most recent
studies on setting goals and writing
them out or typing them out on your
computer
will actually increase your chances of
achieving those goals by
up to 42 percent why well
as soon as you put the energy to writing
out your goals and getting clarity
you're giving your brain the instruction
that this is what's important to you
this is what you want to achieve so
don't be
like all the other people where they
have goals and dreams and they hope and
pray for it to work
be the type of person who sets her goals
or his goals
in writing and then focus on that every
day and you'll achieve more of your
goals
rule number three change your beliefs
there's something in the
weight loss industry field called the
fat set point
and every brain has a fat set point and
it basically states that you have a set
point just like a thermostat
that's programmed in a room to have a
set point
we have fat set points we have financial
set points we have relationship
set points we have these set points that
we become accustomed to achieving
and then all of the supporting evidence
the stories the themes the plot lines
the perceptions and behaviors all must
match the set point
and so you can ask yourself two
questions number one is how did that set
point get there
and then how do i change it right so how
it got there is through all of your
conditioning
through what you've read what you've
done what you've experienced what you've
been told what you've seen
all of that has created your financial
set point
based on your story and so the first
thing to recognize
is the set point can be changed and the
question is how
right and that's the million dollar
question so number one uh
what drives behavior more than anything
else it's not skill
it's not knowledge skill and knowledge
is potential power but what
does drive behavior more anything else
is beliefs
and so if there is a belief
in the brain that says yes you know i
think i'm capable of achieving
double my income would just use double
my income but there's another
belief that opposes that that causes
what we
we know is as neural um dissonance
so it creates a chaotic vibration in the
brain between the conscious and
non-conscious mind
so the key is to get alignment between
the new goal which is a
conscious pattern of thought that you
can choose in an instant
and the non-conscious part of the brain
around that goal
so how do you develop a belief right so
it's a pattern so
if i gave you a sentence and
you said that sentence one time you
probably it's great to be a sentence
like when i was like hearing a line in a
song
one time but if you heard a line in a
song
repeatedly 20 30 40 50 times
and you had other associations with that
to reinforce that pattern then you would
start to develop a non-conscious
pattern through that so we know that
using let's say visualization you're
actually
bypassing the conscious mind and you're
accessing
the visual cortex of the brain it's a
non-conscious process the visual
processor
and so if we take words and we affirm
them and we
feel them and we visualize and repeat
them 100
200 500 000 times now we start to create
a pattern at the non-conscious level
that basically reinforces a conscious
desire
rule number four find the right customer
a lot of people ask me about
money all the time it's one of the
things we teach people how to do is grow
their businesses and how to make more
money
and they say well you know i want to
make more money i said well in order to
make more money
first you have to believe that you can
right
then you have to believe you deserve it
then you have to make sure that you have
something that you can earn money with
so it's either going to be your ideas
you want to you can sell your ideas
yeah like a trainer um you can sell your
time
you can sell your products you can sell
your services
which means that you have to have some
skill
or you have to have somebody else who
could do it for you you have to see your
skill right
well you have to either see your skill
or determine what skills are needed
okay and if you don't have it get
somebody else who has it to help you
and so when when somebody tells me i
want to make more money i say them
let's say we have a pen i don't have a
pen here but if we had a pen
yes and we wanted to make money we could
go
and find somebody who wants to buy this
pen
right now and how much is somebody
willing to pay for the pen
well if the pen is worth a dollar maybe
you can get a dollar for it but what
about finding somebody
who needs it because they have to sign a
contract that's due
in 10 minutes that person might pay a
hundred dollars for that pen
yeah so our job is to take
you know our skills our knowledge our
products our services
our abilities and to be able to present
it to people who need it and
want it in exchange for money
hey this john assaraf and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much
wisdom in books you get to take somebody
else's knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm gonna read a little
bit from
chapter number one and um
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you are
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star rule number five use your
life
i think feeling and knowing that you've
used your life in a way that makes
yourself
proud that you're proud of you you felt
like
what a journey and i left it all out on
the field
and i just left it all in the field
that's my own greatness
you know knowing that i used my life in
a way that i left it
all out on the field that the the
bruises the bangs
you know the trials the tribulations the
highs the lows that
you used it rule number six take
responsibility
as soon as you blame shame or
justify you are disempowering yourself
instead of being responsible
for your emotions your feelings your
attitude
and your actions when you take
responsibility
then you are not at the mercy of the
outside world and what
happens in the outside world you
learn how to upgrade your emotional
ability so whether you are happy or sad
or disgusted or frustrated or angry or
fearful you know how to navigate the
emotions that causes either the
motivational center in your brain to
light up or the fear center in your
brain to light up
thereby causing you to stop and
procrastinate and not take
action rule number seven ask for help
everybody can be an entrepreneur but
i don't want anybody to go and be an
entrepreneur who's got a lot of passion
you know for a product or a service or
something that they love
without realizing that there are many
hats that you have to wear
right there's the person who has to know
all the little details
there's the person who has to have the
vision there's the person who has to
manage there's a person who has to
create the strategies the tactics of
what to do
then there's the person has to drive
those forward those are six different
things that have to be done just
different hats in a business
that most entrepreneurs aren't aware of
yeah and so they they start and they're
busy and they're working really hard
they go god this is hard
yeah and it is hard and they think that
they have to do it all themselves
and that's not the that's not the truth
yeah you have to learn to delegate right
yeah well you can delegate
you can partner with people you can
barter with people there's a variety of
different ways to do it but first you
have to know
what you don't know it's not easy
well it's not easy if you're the one
trying to figure it out
but if you talk to somebody or hire
somebody who's an expert
they'll tell you in seconds and so you
know when you came over here
you know and you're setting up all your
cameras and your lights and all that
stuff you did that in 15 minutes if i
was to that would take me
15 days because you're playing at this
yeah you've done 150 interviews now
right yes and so
so you already know you've learned 150
you know uh
times and a setup and takedown and
mistakes and what to do right what to do
wrong what you need to have backups for
what to do for editing for lighting for
daytime for nighttime for clouds
if the voice works if the sound there's
hundreds of things you have to learn
just for this yeah oh and you have to be
an excellent interviewer too right yes
yeah so there's so many things that you
didn't know when you first started this
yeah that now you know so imagine if i
wanted to
do what you do yeah i could say well you
know what i'm going to do this i'm going
to go and figure out which cameras to
buy and which lighting to buy and how
many batteries do i need and how many
wires do i need
and how many plugs do i need for the
walls and how many backup systems do i
need
i could try to figure all that out or i
could say to you
can you do me a favor yeah can you give
me a list
of what to do what not to do what to buy
what not to buy how much it should be
where i should buy it
you could say yeah i could do that in
one or two hours yeah
i could save months if not a year of my
time
time and money and everything right and
so i much prefer
to find the specialized knowledge
and pay for that and just apply it
rule number eight get into alignment
if you don't understand that every brain
has an
error detection mechanism within it okay
what is that anytime you
veer out of your comfort zone the fat
point
setting or the financials anytime you
veer out of it
the first line of defense is self-talk
that's negative
that's the first thing that pops up
because your brain is going that's not
true
so it's detecting an error between what
you said as an affirmation or even what
you just visualized or even what you
just
did against the predominant neural
patterns that exist
so it's an 800 pound gorilla initially
fighting the flea
right dan heath's book and so what we
want to do is we want to get the
the conscious goal the vision aligned
with a
non-conscious pattern and as soon as you
align that you have neural coherence and
when you have neural coherence
that's like hearing your most favorite
band
playing your favorite song and you're
just like oh that's the best
yeah it's just bliss if it's not bliss
you're out of coherence
and so the key and why we start off
early with meditation is awareness of
how do i tune in my vibration how do i
let go
of that unempowered self-talk that
sentence that thought that i had
or that disempowering it's an unpleasant
feeling beliefs aren't good or bad
they're only pleasant to
unpleasant at varying degrees when we're
at a coherence it's
unpleasant unless our life is on the
line and safety is there for the most
part
you know a fear of failing where is that
coming from
we failed our whole lives successfully
yeah but the meaning that we're giving
you know uh what people will say what
people think
you know how i'll be embarrassed or
ashamed those are all the things that
you need to
really get in tune with rule number nine
upgrade your skills
every level of success that you want to
achieve
in health wealth relationships career
business etc
requires a new understanding
of a skill and a new behavioral pattern
what got you to where you are is
not enough to get you to where you want
to go
why do i say that because if it was
enough to get you to where you want to
go you would
already be there so what got you here
will not get you there maybe some
stepping stones
but every level of success
requires a new level of
skill and behavior and i'm gonna go back
to one of the other lessons
since we develop beliefs and habits
and behaviors that go from conscious
effort
to non-conscious habits in order to
achieve the next level of success
you have to learn how to create new
habits of thought
new emotional management skills and new
behaviors to
match the level of success that you want
to achieve
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip
is turn your stories into fuel because
i felt dumb i read thousands of books
and did hundreds of courses
and because i didn't feel like i was
smart enough
i took the thing that could have
i guess made my life a mess and turned
it into
my fuel for success and because
i lived with parents that
didn't have a great marriage i ended up
divorcing twice but because of
all of those things i studied
and researched and and dove deep into
who do i need to be to have a great
relationship what communication skills
must i have
um who can i model that had a great
relationship
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just
a 35 chance if you just got motivated
but never created a specific plan and
when you share your plan publicly and
have some accountability you
increase your chances even further of
actually following through
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway and your plan of action this
week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
one of my keys to success was that
the path of least resistance is to learn
from somebody who's
already achieved the success you want to
achieve
i always looked for experts
that already tried a thousand things and
found the one or two things that
actually work so i've taken a shortcut
and that's why i was able to become a
multi-millionaire before i was 30.
i just followed individuals that were
worth over 100 million dollars
i followed people that were healthy that
figured out all the stuff that doesn't
work
and gave me the blueprints the map of
what
did work so i went to specialized
knowledge
versus information
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there